- [Woman] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for education and noncommercial use only.
(soft music)
- Well good afternoon.
I'm William Lester, professor of chemistry
and chair of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
We're pleased, along with
the graduate counsel,
to present Professor Richard Thaler,
this year's speaker in the Charles M.
and Martha Hitchcock Series.
As a condition of this
request, we're obligated
and happy to tell you
how the endowment came
to UC Berkeley.
It's a story that
exemplifies the many ways
this campus is linked to
the history of California
and the Bay area.
Doctor Charles Hitchcock,
a physician in the army,
came to San Francisco
during the gold rush,
where he opened a thriving practice.
In 1885, Charles
established a professorship
here at Berkeley, as an
expression of his long
held interest in education.
His daughter, Lily Hitchcock Coit,
still treasured in San Francisco for her
colorful personality, as
well as her generosity,
greatly expanded her
father's original gift
to establish a professorship
at UC Berkeley,
making it possible for us to
present a series of lectures.
The Hitchcock fund has
become one of the most
cherished endowments of the
University of California,
recognizing the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
Thank you Lily and Charles,
and now a few words
about Professor Thaler.
Richard Thaler is renowned
for his influential
contributions over the last three decades
to the emerging field
of behavioral economics.
He is considered by many to be the pioneer
in integrating psychological research
with economic theory and the inventor
of the field of behavioral economics.
Thaler's studies also
focus on behavioral finance
and the psychology of decision making.
He explores the implications of loosening
the standard economic
assumption that everyone
in the economy is rational and selfish.
Instead considering the
possibility that some
of the participants in the
economy are sometimes human.
Thaler received his BA from
Case Western Reserve University
in 1967 and his MA and PhD
from the University of Rochester in 1970
and '74 respectively.
Between 1974 and 1980,
he held the positions
of assistant professor
at the graduate school
of management of the
University of Rochester.
And assistant professor of economics
and public administration at the graduate
School of Business and
Public Administration
at Cornell University.
From 1980 to 1988 he was
professor of economics
at Cornell's Johnson Graduate
School of Management.
He is currently the Robert P. Gwen
Professor of Behavioral
Science and Economics,
as well as director of the
Center of Decision Research
at the University of Chicago,
Graduate School of Business,
where he has help appointments since 1995.
Thaler is also a research associate
at the National Bureau
of Economic Research,
where he co-directs the
behavioral economics project.
Professor Thaler has been
awarded numerous honors
for his extensive and illuminating work
in behavioral economics.
He is a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences
and in 2009, he was elected a fellow
of the American Finance Association.
And currently serves as vice president
of the American Economics Association.
Please join me in welcoming
Professor Richard Thaler.
(applauding)
- Okay, well first of
all I have some good news
to announce, the Giants
won three, nothing.
(applauding)
You can go now.
So it's a great honor to be here
and so I think I have more
friends at this university
than any other and I also have a daughter
and daughter in law in the audience today
so it's lots of fun to be here.
Let me start by talking about my so-called
friend, Danny Kahneman,
who some of you may know,
he was a professor here,
much beloved professor
for many years before he,
ditched Berkeley and went to Princeton.
And Danny and I have
been friends since 1977.
So once when I was out
here for some reason
and Danny and I were doing
some work at this home
up in the hills.
He had to get a phone
call from some reporter
who was writing a story
about me, a profile.
So I was there, it was a little awkward.
We were both, Danny and
I were worried about
whether I would be
embarrassed by the effusive
praise that he would be heaping upon me,
but we decided not to
share with the reporter
that I was in the room.
So they're starting the
talking and then Danny says,
"Well, really the best thing about Thaler
"is that he's lazy."
(laughing)
So I'm, you know, waving at him
and writing him a note saying, you know,
it's not the best thing, right?
So he and I have been arguing
about this ever since.
But the truth is that he's right.
I don't know whether it's the best thing,
but it's an accurate description.
And so I was a lazy man
going into economics
and what was I to do?
So what's a good research
method for a lazy guy?
Introspection.
Now the scientific name for
this is thought experiment
and I've actually developed
some very little known
statistical methods for
analyzing thought experiments.
I think I'm the only person that has
those statistical packages.
So here's my first thought experiment.
When I was living in
Rochester, a friend of mine
were given two tickets
to a basketball game,
this was when Buffalo had a
professional basketball team.
There was a big blizzard which
was not a surprising event,
and we wisely decided
not to go to the game.
And he says, it would be
nuts to go to this game
in this weather.
But then he says, but if we had paid
for those tickets we would be going.
Now this of course, is a
violation of economic theory
because in economics we teach,
thou shalt ignore sunk costs.
But we were going, so it
started me wondering why.
But I discovered the
hard way that you can't
publish thought experiments.
Do the next best thing,
which is ask other people
to engage in thought experiments.
So while I was working
on my doctoral thesis,
which was on the value of a human life,
that was an econometric exercise,
where I was estimated how
much you had to pay people
to get them to take risky jobs.
I thought it might be fun
to ask them some questions.
So I asked two questions.
The first was, we can
modify it for this crowd,
suppose that by coming to this lecture
you have exposed yourself
to a one in a thousand
risk of death.
If you have this disease, you're gonna die
a quick and painless
death, sometime next week.
But I have one cure
that I'm willing to sell
to the highest bidder,
how much will you pay?
So you can think about your
answer to that question.
Then I asked another question.
How much would you
demand to expose yourself
to that risk?
Typical answers to
those questions would be
something like, $1,000
and one million dollars.
But economic theory tells
us that those answers
should be approximately the same,
so how can they differ by
several orders of magnitude?
So this got me thinking.
I was told that,
this experiment was
criticized on the grounds
that it was hypothetical.
I've been trying ever
since to do it for...
Real, you know, I thought
Russian Roulette for money.
Somehow I haven't gotten that past any
human subject committees,
so this was career stifling.
So then I moved on to
more advanced methods.
In 1991, '92, my friend Colin Camerer,
one of the first people to join me in this
behavioral economics
venture, he and Danny and I
were all spending a year in New York
and if you live in New
York you spend a lot
of time in cabs.
So Colin and I used to
talk to cab drivers a lot.
And what they told us was
that if they were having
a particularly good day, they
would quit and go home early.
This is the opposite
of what economic theory
tells them they should
do because essentially,
what they're doing is they're minimizing
their earnings per hour by working less
on the profitable days and
more on the unprofitable days.
Then I moved on to playing
poker with my colleagues,
that was another data collection method.
And what I noticed was
that full professors
of economics would be
entirely different people
depending on whether
they were ahead or behind
by some relatively small amount, like $50.
So if they were ahead by $50,
there was no point in
trying to bluff them.
They would call any bet that didn't risk
putting them behind.
But if they were behind,
they didn't like getting
much further behind, but
they were willing to gamble
if they could get back to even.
So again, it was hard to
publish my poker predictions
and in any case, that would've deprived me
of an important income source when I
was a young professor.
So all of this got, all
of these observations,
scientific observations
got me thinking about
what I've called mental accounting,
which is how people think
about everyday transactions.
Why is it that they think that having paid
for those tickets makes
it seem more compelling
that they should go to the game?
Why does the cab driver
think it's a good idea
to quit when they're
making a lot of money?
Why do they treat opposite costs different
from out of pocket costs?
And more important was how to convince
any of my colleagues that any of these
observations were remotely
interesting or compelling.
So essentially, today I'm
gonna tell you the story of
how I began going beyond
thought experiments.
So one method is to try real experiments.
Here's an experiment that Danny Kahneman
and Jack Kinnech and I ran.
It was run actually in a class at Cornell
in law and economics.
For the economists in
the room, this is a class
in which the coast theorem was mentioned
at least once in every lecture.
So we handed out Cornell coffee mugs
to every other student.
And then created a market in these mugs.
And if they had a mug they could sell it.
If they didn't have a
mug, they could buy it.
Now since there was
random assignment of mugs,
the economic theory and
particularly the coast theorem
suggests that it makes
it, and kind of an unusual
prediction of economics, it makes a
prediction about volume.
Normally we have predictions about prices.
We rarely have predictions about quantity.
But this one makes a
prediction about volume,
specifically it says that about half
the mugs should trade.
And the reason is, suppose you rank
the students in this
class based on how much
they love a Cornell coffee mug.
There were 44 students in this class.
The 22 who liked mugs most
should end up owning them,
and about 11 of them should have gotten
a mug at random so the
other 11 should buy a mug.
Well that didn't happen.
Instead of a volume of 11 trades,
we would get a volume
between one and four.
The reason why we didn't get volume
is the people who got mugs
didn't wanna part with them
and the people who didn't get a mug,
weren't that interested in buying one.
I've called this the endowment effect.
The idea is that once
something is in your endowment
you don't wanna give it up.
But you wouldn't pay much to get it.
This experiment was criticized,
well this is small stakes.
So here's another experiment that was,
this was an experiment
I conducted to try to
test my observations at the poker table.
This was done with real money.
It can be sometimes
difficult to run experiments
with real money where
people can lose money,
but we had an unusually intelligent
human subjects committee at Cornell,
so I was able to run these.
So the first group of students are told,
you've just won $30, truthfully.
Now would you like to flip
a coin for nine dollars.
And the 70, 30 means 70% said yes.
Another group are told, you just lost $30,
they had bad luck.
Now would you like to flip
a coin for nine dollars?
If you're wondering what we did with these
poor subjects who lost money,
the experiment was designed in such a way
that that was fairly unlikely to happen
and they were told that if they didn't
wanna pay they could
go to the library and xerox articles.
Believe it or not, people
used to go to libraries
and xerox articles, if you
can imagine such a thing,
and we would pay them for that activity.
But anyway, you can see,
after having lost money,
they're not as interested
in this coin flip.
But if we say you've lost
$30, now would you like
$10 for sure or a one
third chance to get 30,
now they're back into
gambling because this gives
them a chance to break even.
Now this experiment
illustrates two things.
The first we've called
the house money effect.
This is a gambling term.
If you go to a casino
you'll sometimes see people
who win some money, they'll take the money
they've won, they put it one pocket.
They take the money they brought with them
and they put it into another pocket.
And the money they've won is referred to
as the house money,
the casino is the house
and it's like, that's
somebody else's money.
They don't mind losing that money,
but they hate losing their own money.
And the problem three
illustrates what we've
called the break even effect.
That people hate losing,
but if they get a chance
to get back to even, they'll
gamble in order to take it.
Now we have real money, real stakes,
but people say, well this is peanuts.
This is small stakes.
And now people have
tried raising the stakes
creatively by going to a poor country.
So you can play games like this for
the same amount of US dollars, but can be
three months income.
But there's another way
of raising the stakes
and that's to use game shows.
I wrote a paper with
three Greek colleagues,
using the game show Deal or No Deal.
Now if you've never seen
this show, you're lucky.
It's pretty much unwatchable.
I'll explain how it works.
So we had data from the Dutch show,
the US show, and now I'm
forgetting, German show.
The US show was high stakes.
You could win up to a million dollars.
The Dutch show, the first
prize was five million euros,
which is about 50 billion dollars.
(laughing)
Here's the way this game works,
in the US version they had
to sex the US version up,
there are brief cases with
various amounts of money.
In the US version the
stakes were a little lower,
but it's the same idea.
In the US version each
briefcase is held on stage
by a scantily clad model.
And the first step the contestant,
this guy's name is Frank,
names six of the cases
that he wants opened.
Oh no, I forgot an important step.
First he picks a case and
they bring it up on stage.
That's his, whatever amount
of money is in there,
it could be any of these amounts, is his.
Now he opens six cases and
the amounts are revealed.
Notice, this tells him
what isn't in his case.
So he's got one of the
remaining amounts of money.
At this point, he's offered
a choice, deal or no deal?
The offer, in this case
you can see at the top,
is 17,000 pounds, sorry euros
and he can say deal or no deal.
At the bottom, we've
calculated and are showing you
the expected value.
So on average, what he
would get if he played
this game a lot times.
And you can see that's 383,000 euros,
so this is a very bad offer.
And in fact, the offers
always start out low
and no one ever takes them.
And that's designed to
make the show watchable.
So you can see Frank was quite
lucky in this first round.
He didn't open any of the big briefcases.
The US host frequently reminds
guests that the strategy
is to pick the breifcases
with small amounts of money,
which is undoubtedly the
right strategy in this game.
I think that's a game theory result.
Frank's luck turns immediately.
So on the second round he opens up a bunch
of really big numbers.
You can see his expected
value falls to 64,000 euros,
and his offer falls, he says no.
I'm gonna go through the
rest kind of quickly.
You can watch how Frank does.
(laughing)
now notice at this point, Frank
has quite a risky portfolio.
Right?
He's got one big number, one decent number
and three tiny numbers.
He's being offered 75% of expected value,
that's a pretty good deal.
In fact, we would expect
him to take that deal,
but he says no deal.
Very unlucky.
So he keeps playing.
Now at this point, he's offered
more than expected value.
So he's offered 6,000 euros
for a 50% chance at 10,000.
He says no.
Okay, this is...
There's a lot of things going on here.
One of them is that the very big stakes
that he started with sort of blind him
to the fact that this is
actually a high stakes bet.
So any other day of Frank's life,
if you walked up to him and said,
would you like 6,000 euros for sure,
or a 50% chance at 10,000?
He would say, thank you very
much and take the 6,000,
but today, no.
Now let me show you, this is
some German, Helga, I think.
I'm not making that up.
And now you can see the German show
is much smaller stakes.
But it works, the rules are just the same.
Helen is quite lucky.
And now this is the house money effect.
Here we're offering
exactly an even money bet,
and she says, fine I'll gamble.
I watched about three
or four of the US shows
and then couldn't bear it anymore
and then hired a student to watch them
and record what happens.
Don't report to the IRB.
But in one of the shows I saw a scene
kind of similar to this and this was
a first grade teacher who,
the stakes were kind of
similar to this in dollars,
and she said no deal.
The host said why and she says,
"Well it's only $25,000."
Now that was six month's income.
And there is again no
other context in which
she would say, "It's only
25,000," but she did here.
So this was one way of
us raising the stakes
and there is lots of boring sophisticated
econometrics in this
paper if you're interested
in reading it, but essentially we're able
to test a version of prospect theory,
which is a theory of choice
that Kahneman and Traversky came up with
and we get quite a bit of
evidence supporting it.
And remarkably, the
behavior is very similar
to what I observed in the poker game
and what we observed in
our low stakes experiments.
One of the results of
mental accounting is that...
What explains this behavior
about driving in the snow,
one way to describe it
is to say that people
don't like closing an account,
a mental account in the loss.
So they bought those
tickets, and now if they
throw them away, they're out that money.
Again, this is small stakes, anecdotal.
Can we raise the stakes somehow?
so your own, Terry Odean
has run some experiments about...
Sorry, a study on this
with real investors.
Here's the hypothetical experiment
that you wanna think about.
Suppose you need $30,000,
you're gonna sell one
of two stocks you own.
One has gone up and one has gone down.
Which one do you sell?
Now the rational choice
is to sell the loser.
And the reason is the government,
or benevolent government
likes to share and they share
our gains and our losses.
And if you dislike paying
taxes than you would
rather share your losses
with the government
than your gains.
But that's not what people do.
So this is Terry's data and
what he's looking at here
is the, in people's
portfolios what percentage
of their winners did they sell
and what percentage of
the losers did they sell
and what you can see is that they sell
15% of the winners and 10% of the losers.
Now in December, when taxes get relevant,
they get just barely rational.
So the sell slightly
more losers than winners
in that month, but the
rest of the year, no.
Now you might think,
ah, they're being smart.
And they realized that these
losers are gonna rebound,
but in fact, that's not true.
The stocks they sell do
worse than the stocks
they hold on to.
Some additional evidence with finance,
with cabs, actually I think
I took the finance out,
with football and another game show.
After our driving around experience,
Colin and I went to some guy.
It might have been Danny Devito,
who was the dispatcher
for some taxi cab company.
In New York many of the taxi
drivers fill out some sheet
that records every fair.
And so we got a big pile
of these that we analyzed.
And we did this with Linda
Babcock and George Loewenstein.
And what we found was some
evidence to support this
intuition the cab drivers
had shared with us,
that on days where in
the first half of the day
they were doing well, first of all,
we had evidence that
that was a good predictor
of earnings in the second half of the day,
and second that they were more
likely to quit on those days.
So you can think of it as
a reason why you can never
get a cab on a rainy day in New York,
is all the cab drivers have gone home
because they've made so much money.
So we declared victory.
Then came along a very mean and evil guy
called Hank Farber.
Oh, before I get to Hank,
who's actually quite
a lovable guy but...
This result was only true
for inexperienced drivers.
So we divided our sample in half.
To the old ones and the young
ones, just a median split
and the older drivers had figured this out
and got it more or less right.
The younger ones were making this mistake.
So here's the quiz.
Does this finding imply that cab drivers
are less likely to show up on a day
expected to be busy?
Okay.
The answer is no.
Surprisingly enough
though, one leading journal
published a paper that shows that people
who work in stadiums are
more likely to show up
on days like today when
the ballpark is full
than on days early in the season
when there's nobody there.
Now this is not surprising
or contradictory
of anything we found.
Cab drivers are more likely to show up
on a day that's busy too,
they're just more likely
to quit early.
So it might have been
hard to find a beer vendor
in the eighth inning today.
Now we get to, no.
More evidence, I'm
holding Hank in reserve.
There's also a study by Ernst Fehr
and his student, Lorenze Goette who find
the same data for bike messengers
in a field experiment they conducted.
But now we get to the evil Hank Farber,
who analyzes our data to death
and gets the data to confess.
Essentially what he finds
is that the evidence
that the first half of the day predicts
earnings in the second
half of the day is too weak
to draw our conclusion,
which was very depressing.
But to the rescue comes Vince Crawford
and one of his students, J.J Meng,
who combined even fancier econometrics
with even fancier theory
provided by Berkeley's
none other than Botond
Koszegi and Matthew Rabin
and determined the truth.
Now if I could install
a ban on anymore papers
on cab drivers, I would
like to do that right now,
but at least right now,
I don't know whether
this paper is out yet, but
it's forthcoming in 2010.
I'm declaring victory, I'm moving on.
One of my colleagues somehow
has not been convinced
by all this.
There was an article in the
University of Chicago Magazine,
a profile of me and
they went to talk to my
Nobeloreatte college, Gary Becker,
who's the chief defender of
the rational economic model.
And this was his comment.
Gaze, I'll let you read it
because I need a sip of water.
He basic, the translation is,
no need to pay any attention to Thaler.
This doesn't matter.
Presumably cab drivers don't count.
So we decided to turn to
National Football League teams.
Now this, you would think,
remember he's claiming
that the 10% of people who
know what they're doing
will end up in the important
jobs and presumably,
you have to be really rich
to own a football team.
It costs about a billion dollars.
I want one.
If anyone has that kind
of money, come talk to me
after the lecture, I want
somebody to knock off Al Davis.
And then we'll buy the Raiders.
And I'll prove to you
in the next 10 minutes
that we'll turn them into winners.
So let's see whether owners
of National Football League
teams satisfy rationality
according to Becker.
So what we do is we don't
study the game itself.
You don't need to know
the difference between
a quarterback and a
linebacker, which is good
since my daughter's in
the room and doesn't know
the difference between a
quarterback and a linebacker
although her boyfriend is trying hard
to explain the difference.
Every year in April,
the teams have a draft
where they pick so called college players.
They did attend some college.
(laughing)
I'm sure the ones at Cal
are serious students.
And they pick players
in order with the worst
team picking first.
There are seven rounds of this draft
and the players who are picked by a team
are stuck with that team for a period of,
typically four or five years.
Crucially, for what we do,
those picks can and are traded.
And so what we study is
the market for picks.
And we wanna know whether
that market is efficient.
So let me show you what
that market looks like.
This is a plot of all the trades of,
this is all the trades
just picks for picks.
Sometimes teams will
trade a player for a pick.
We can't analyze those in this way,
so we only look at the data
that are picks for picks.
And we estimate a curve to fit that data
and if you ever looked at real data,
you know it doesn't look like this.
This has an R square
that's embarrassingly high.
I mean, it's .99.
So at first, this is a
paper done with one of my
former students, Cade
Matthews, now at Yale.
We thought maybe we had
discovered Newton's fourth law,
or something like that.
It turns out that wasn't the case.
What we had discovered was something
that in the league they
refer to as, the chart.
It turns out some time in
the '90s, the Dallas Cowboys
had one of Jerry Jone's
co-owners, an engineer,
estimate that curve.
And calculate just from past trades,
what picks were worth.
And he fiddled around, it was
nothing very sophisticated.
And then since he was dealing
with mere football owners,
he produced this chart and what it's...
I'm sure it's hard to read in the back.
What it says is the
very first pick up here
is worth 3,000 points.
The last pick, what they
call Mr. Irrelevant,
is worth not quite a point.
And then the second pick is
2,600, 2,200 and so forth.
Well what we were estimating
essentially is this chart
because the chart has
spread all around the league
and teams all have it, and
now when they conduct trades,
they're all looking at this chart.
So if the Raiders, they
always have one of these
picks up here so...
(laughing)
So Al Davis has the third
pick, he's talking to the guy
with the 12th pick about a trade,
that there's a difference
of a thousand points.
So the guy with the 12th pick will have to
come up with some number of
picks that equals a thousand.
The picks, the trades follow
this chart very, very closely.
Now what we're interested in is,
is this chart right in the sense that
is the first pick really worth three times
as much as the 16th pick?
Or is the first pick worth
four of these picks down here?
And our guess was the answer was no.
That was our strong
intuition, but as I told you
I've had trouble getting
my intuitions published,
so we collected some data.
One aside, since the chart came out,
so this is when the first chart was done,
two things have happened.
One is it's become more
true in the sense that
this is the variance away from the chart.
And so at the beginning only
the Cowboys had this chart.
But then a guy from
the Cowboys would leave
and go to the Niners and
he would take it with him
and in spread around the league.
Now everyone has it.
And so this curve here is plotting
the deviation away from the
chart and this moves it out.
And what you can see is the chart starts
to fit better and better as
everyone starts to use it.
What we conclude so far is that the market
values high picks very highly.
Now is that correct?
So the next question we wanna ask is,
what do you have to pay these guys?
Well, here's another chart.
This is how much you have to pay picks
as a function of draft order.
And you can see these early
picks are also really expensive.
You also see, this curve
also has a really good fit.
There's not our chart, instead the league,
the league has a chart, essentially.
Because there's, I'm not
gonna go into detail here,
but there is something
called a rookie salary cap
and the league is basically telling teams
how much they can pay
rookies and it's this.
And so players are pretty much slotted.
The first guy makes more than
the second guy and so forth.
So high picks are expensive in two ways.
The picks are expensive and
the players are expensive.
Now what that means is a
team should only be willing
to take a very high pick
if they're really sure
this guy is good.
Now if any of you are 49ers fans,
you probably know a guy called Alex Smith.
When was he drafted?
Anyway, 2001?
Okay.
That year the Niner's had the first pick.
They spent about six
weeks trying to decide
whether Alex Smith or Aaron Rogers
was the better quarterback.
In the end they went with Smith.
Now it's a very close call.
It should have been,
in fact what we find is
that the chance that the
first quarterback taken
is better than the second is about 52%.
And that's true throughout the draft.
Here's a plot of that.
What this shows is consecutive players
at some position, what's the chance
the Nth guy is better
than the Nth plus first?
And it's a little higher
in the first round,
it's maybe 55, 56 percent.
But then it gets to
coin flips very quickly.
So you should be worried about that chart.
So here's the last step.
What we do is we take and
value player's performance
and we value them by how much
you have to pay veterans.
And so here's what you have to pay.
This is what you have to pay veterans.
These are all pros, the best players.
The blue line are quarterbacks,
so quarterbacks get
paid about twice as much
as everybody else.
Other players, there's not that much
difference between positions.
Defensive ends get paid a lot
and left tackles get paid a lot.
But essentially what we
do is we take Alex Smith
and we say, in his first year,
let's say he was a backup quarterback.
That's worth three million.
Second year, below average quarterback.
Third year, fourth year, fifth year,
below average quarterback.
And we add those all up and we say,
all right that's what he
was worth to the Niner's.
Here's what we get.
What we find, first of all,
this is what players are worth.
Now you can see they know something,
the teams know something.
First picks are worth
more than the, right.
So value goes down with the draft.
But not fast enough.
These are the...
If you subtract payment
this is surplus, so this
is what the picks are worth
to the players and you can see
according to us, the
best picks in the draft
are at the beginning of the second round.
Now just to summarize, here is the curve
we were trying to test
of whether it's rational.
Here's what we think is truth.
It's not close.
This is the biggest, I've
done a lot of research
in behavioral finance, this is much bigger
mis-pricing than anything we've found.
What this says is that you
can trade the first pick
for about five or six second round picks,
each of which is worth more
than that pick you gave up.
So of course, the Niner's
should have traded that pick.
I was actually interviewed by
a reporter around that time
and asked, if you were the
Niner's what would you do
and I said, I would put
that pick on sale, 20% off.
They didn't do that.
Last comment about football.
Various complaints about our methods.
Here's a simple analysis we've conducted.
Let's consider all the trades,
one player for two players.
See how they do.
On two measures, number
of all pro appearances
and number of starts.
This is what we get.
We get, the technical term is dominance.
You get just as many pro bowl players
and the same number of...
You get just as many pro bowl
appearances, that's over here,
but a lot more starts.
So this is sort of a non-parametric test.
Okay.
One more game show.
So this is a high stakes
prisoner's dilemma.
You know what, while
we're messing with this,
we're gonna listen.
There's a middle-aged man and a rather
attractive young woman.
- The jackpot today
is 100,150 pounds.
- Listen carefully.
(applauding)
- You have one final decision to make.
- A easy decision.
- We're now going to play split or steal.
(applauding)
I know you're the last
two people in the country
I have to explain this
to, but you have two
final golden balls.
You each have a golden ball with the word
split written inside.
steal written inside.
You will make a conscious choice
of choosing the split or the steal ball.
If you both choose
- He's nodding.
- The split ball, you
split today's jackpot
of 100,150 pounds
- She's nodding.
- And you go home with 50,075 pounds.
(cheering)
If one of you splits
and one of you steals,
whoever chooses the
steal ball will go home
with 100,150 pounds.
- He's shaking his head.
- And the person who chooses the
split ball
- She's looking scared.
- Goes home with nothing.
If you both choose the steal
ball, you go home with nothing.
Okay.
Before I ask you to
choose, I want you to look
at your two golden balls
and make sure you know
which is the split ball and
which is the steal ball.
This is very important.
Make sure you don't show each other.
- All right, now they're looking
at their balls and checking.
- Before I ask you to choose,
I think you have some
talking to do to each other.
- Steven, I just hope there
weren't puppy dog tears
and they were real tears
and you were genuinely
gonna split that money.
- I am going to split this.
50,000.
I'm just, that's unbelievable.
I'm very, very happy
to go home with 50,000.
- You are genuinely going
to split the money with me?
- If I stole off you every
- She's almost tearing up.
single person over there would
run over here and lynch me.
- There was no way I could.
I mean everyone who knew me would just
be disgusted if I stole.
- When people watch this,
they're not gonna believe it.
- Please, do not--
- She's reaching out
- Sarah, I can look you
straight in the eye
- and touching his hand
at this point.
- and tell you
I am going to split.
- Promise?
- I swear, don't you.
I am going to split.
- Okay.
This is serious money.
Now, we're gonna take a vote
on what you think happens.
(laughing)
All right, there's two
decisions, split or to steal.
You couldn't see the faces, but probably
doesn't matter that much.
How many of you think
that the guy will split?
Okay.
How many think the gal will split?
Slightly more, but about 50/50.
Okay, here's what happens.
- Here it is.
- Sarah, Steve, choose either the split
or the steal ball now.
Hold it up.
- We're going on the 50 grand
each, I promise you that.
(intense music)
- [Host] Split or steal.
(screaming)
- So he split, she steals.
- You never know what's
coming in this game.
- He has his hands like this.
- Congratulations, Sarah.
You have just won
- He's looking kinda mortified
- 100,150 pounds.
(cheering)
Steven, Steven, I'm so sorry.
- Okay, so.
This is now the second in
my all star game series,
show series of papers.
And it's done with one of my Dutch friends
from the previous paper.
And so the first question
is, there have been
literally thousands of papers
written about the prisoner's dilemma.
None with stakes this big.
What happens if you raise the stakes
to an average of $20,000,
you get amazingly close to the behavior
in laboratory experiments
for a few dollars.
About 45% of the participants split.
Which means
half of that, about 20 some percent
of people leave with money.
Now we study a bunch of things,
I'm not gonna go into detail because we're
kind of running out of time.
Young men steal more
often which means they are
either rational or jerks.
We can't distinguish between those.
There's a question of what
happens with the stake size.
The answer is
cooperation rates are quite a bit higher
when the stakes are very low.
And here's my take on this
and it's the same take
I gave you on the Deal or No Deal,
that these stakes look low
in the context of this game.
And so they know that
they could be playing
for tens of thousands of pounds.
If they are only paying for
200, they know it's peanuts,
why not cooperate?
But once you get up to serious money,
stakes isn't doing much.
And we get about the 40, 45%.
Yeah, so that's what I just said.
Another question you could ask,
so this game is on television.
Does that matter?
And of course the answer must be yes,
but we're not quite sure how it matters.
In the Deal or No Deal, we
actually ran an experiment
with students at smaller stakes,
where we had some play the game in front
of a big audience and some
privately on a computer.
It turns out, quite
surprisingly at least to me,
the people in front of the
audience did not take more risk.
They took a little less.
I would have predicted
the other way around,
but the difference wasn't huge.
So one thing we did here
was we looked at whether
people sort of had some reputational stake
in appearing to be on this.
And we did this by just
categorizing their occupations.
And here's the result that
reputation only mattered
if the stakes were high.
And otherwise, it didn't.
The next thing is, we were interested in,
there's a bunch of
previous rounds that were
four players originally and it seems like
in all game shows you
vote to kick people off.
There's also a lot of, what game theorists
would call tube talk in this game,
where people announce they
have some of these balls
with amounts of money that are hidden
and they announce what they are.
And what we were interested
in is, if you lie about that,
does that make you less trustworthy later?
The answer is no.
It seems that everybody,
it's common knowledge that everybody lies
and everybody thinks that everybody lies.
What often happens is
if a guy is dealt essentially a good hand
and he has the equivalent
of an ace and a king
in his hidden balls, he will
truthfully say what he has
and say, see I'm always
gonna tell you the truth.
And then in the next round
will lie if it's convenient.
So they all lie and they
all know they would lie
so this doesn't matter.
Now the last thing is,
one way of characterizing
behavior in this game
would be four types.
The first would be, I'll call gameboys.
They always defect.
They learned that in
their game theory class
and so they always defect.
Then there could be nice guys
and they always cooperate.
So they always split,
the other ones steal.
Third guys, I'll call them
conditional tit for tatters.
They will cooperate with someone who they
expect to cooperate, and
otherwise they won't.
Then we have the deep tit for tatters.
These are ones who
realize, the game theorists
will know what I'm talking about,
this is a weak prisoner's dilemma game.
And they come up with the
following deep realization.
If the other person is gonna
cooperate, it doesn't matter.
So they might as well cooperate.
So they'll cooperate and if
the other guy cooperates,
great, they'll get half.
If the other guys steals, they were not
gonna get anything anyway,
and they might as well look good on TV.
Now notice A, B, and D are all invariant
to everything else.
So what we do is we investigate whether
we can find any evidence for C.
So is there any evidence that people take
into consideration what they
think the other player might do
and the evidence essentially is no.
It turns out the only
significant predictor of whether
someone will cooperate
is whether they explicity
promise to cooperate.
In the clip I played you,
he does and she doesn't.
He says, "I promise you I will cooperate."
And then she says something like,
"If I didn't, everyone
would think I'm a jerk
"and no one would speak to me."
So if you had our data, you would predict
that he would cooperate
and she would steal,
which that turns out to be right.
There's no version of any
model we could estimate
in which they seemed to pay attention
to any of those things.
So I can't tell you what of
the other things they're doing,
but they don't seem to be doing
this conditional cooperation.
Point one is good economics requires
sensible models of how real people behave.
That's really the radical
departure I had 30 years ago.
You might worry or
wonder, what does this say
about public policy, but
you have to come back
tomorrow to find out.
Thank you very much.
(applauding)
(soft music)